what did you want to tell us what we're
going to watch or should we just see it
it well yes it's somewhat my my wife
actually recorded it on an iPhone in the
trailer and it's Winston Churchill doing
James Brown this annually so here is
Winston Churchill this is so many layers
this is so meta now Gary Coleman does
Winston Churchill doing James Brown for
the Oscar
[Music]
[Applause]
so Allison Williams your co-star that
she gave you a bit of a complex on says
she didn't it was the makeup woman she's
cool but she took him out like the
kitchen in it like yeah yes I was the
kissing scene I don't know if you guys I
don't know maybe he said that word in
England does this yeah so the kissing
scene and then just before it they would
give me like I I didn't know I had my co
actor suddenly just before was seen with
that they came up and gave a mint and I
didn't know if I was gonna take it as a
like a nice thing to do or is it just
like oh my god he thinks my breath is
cool face and then we did another taste
give me another minute that was worth an
issue then took me for the rest of day
because I was at white giving me mints
so in England we don't do that no no
just method
now at the end of the Oscars I don't
know what you're talking about
well so the end of the Oscars when lala
land
didn't win but had won and so there's a
picture of you this is right but I think
you find out that lala land hasn't won
yeah what emotion is this
mini means good well did you see what
the crowd looked like oh we've got a
picture of that the crowd are amazing
Matt Damon looks like he swallowed his
on the seat so I mean it was like they
were watching their childhood homes
catch fire never cared about anything
more
were you there you guys I wasn't I was
shooting in Atlanta at the time I was
watching it on TV though I I had this
similar expression to that yeah
that must have been a bonkers moment
when that all went down well it was you
know interesting but it was you know
unexpected but I thought someone had
been hurt you know the the way everyone
was talking amongst themselves it felt
like someone had had a heart attack or
worse and it felt like some someone was
in danger and they just read the wrong
name I didn't know that one time
apparently is bad etiquette to keep your
tongue yeah I didn't know that
[Applause]
because I thought we keepin it real
[Applause]
party if you fancy them you put your
tongue in that's what someone told me
another Shh thankfully like don't stress
about a bit no tongue and I was like oh
got it I always said to other people I'm
like yeah it's so cool but like no tone
but why wouldn't someone tell you that
why wouldn't wait you're like someone
should have told you that before you put
the tongue no but this is like here's
later conversation said you not supposed
to put your tongue you know was that
what movies doing gangbusters in America
seem really well then your mom arrives
in America and wants to go and see it
yeah so yeah she really wanted to go and
say it and she was really proud and I'd
heard it was doing really well and all
that sort of stuff and I was like mom
it's June really well let's go see it
with a real audience it's probably gonna
be solid a but we'll just go and say if
we can win go way in there so I got us
tickets to like a four o'clock screen
and or something like that and that I
was like keep your head down everywhere
it's it's old and you know the films
doing well all the first oh we go into
the cinema there's a total of six people
in all on their phones nobody who's in
droves at all I was like just keep your
head down keep your head and there was
this girl that was like texting for the
first 10 minutes the phone I was like
get off your phone that turns up late
but she loved her she loved her and and
I think the other six people
the success was very fast everything not
all the additions went that really the
beginning do you know the one I'm
talking about the one with Dino De
Laurentiis Oh
auditioning yes yes yes well that was
for King Kong no yes yes the girl she's
very good yeah that was Dino De
Laurentiis senior and his son had seen
me in a play and so I went up to the top
of the gulf and western building that's
like the 33rd floor and he had this
amazing office that looked all over
Manhattan and he was back there and I
walked in and and his son was sitting
there very excited that he brought in
this new actress and the father said to
his son in Italian because I understand
tiny said gay brutta you know why do you
bring me this ugly thing very sobering
so I said to him me this Piazza Motoman
you know but I understand what you're
saying I'm sorry I'm not beautiful
enough to be in King
well well Quadra petting is a large part
of it
okay so Quadra petting is walking on all
fours and I have with me some some arm
extensions which we could that we could
all ever go with all right and these in
fact are how we quadruped it so we can
all have a go and I think I think we
should so these are these are looking
it's got mark motion capture dots on it
already so we can shoot so anyway so you
so let me just the so first of all you
know if you're gonna get into into being
an eight lucky like them
you're a silverback gorilla then you
tend to have you back side spinning out
if you're if you're chimpanzee then yet
then you're tucked in like this so you
can choose between the gorilla or or to
pick whichever you like
you got kissing tips from a great answer
one of the greatest yeah one of the
greatest Meryl Streep I had to kiss in a
movie called the hours and she was not
happy with the way a certain scene was
being lit and we had to kiss and she
said I'm going to do you a favor you're
gonna thank me for it later can I
demonstrate on you Amy yeah of course
you can
yes please oh no tongue
[Applause]
pineapple over the cameras was it that
one's probably that's our cover right
there okay so you know so I have these
of nasal nasal labial folds they call
them these here and they look better
when they're pulled back so she came in
to kiss me and she went like this she
did for me and actually she pulled my
face back and kiss me and it was it so
you can go watch the movie it's very
funny to see that no I really want you
to win the Oscar it's like kissed you
[Music]